going into the second season of netflix
is the umbrella academy one could easily
think the show couldn't possibly need
many new characters
however any notion that there's no room
for fresh faces on the umbrella academy
is dispelled during one of diego's first
scenes in season two
after the events of the umbrella academy
season 1 sent the gang back to the 1960s
we find diego biding his time as an
asylum inmate due to his attempts to
stop president john f kennedy's
assassination
keeping diego company in the asylum is
an enigmatic inmate named lila pitts who
soon escapes with diego and joins the
hargreaves siblings in their adventures
unfortunately diego's brother 5 is right
to be suspicious of the charming
newcomer
spoiler alert lila is actually on a
secret mission for her adopted mother
who turns out to be none other than
five's former boss the villainous
handler
what's more the season two finale
reveals that just like the hargreaves
siblings lila is one of the 43 babies
born on october 1st 1989
and she possesses superpowers of her own
lila represents huge potential for
future narrative exploration on the
series
and actress ritu arya portrays her with
a cutting playfulness that keeps all the
other characters on their toes
you don't know anything about me
everything about you
you are an open book written for very
dumb children
in fact arya is such a strong on-screen
presence that you may remember seeing
her face somewhere before
since 2013 arya has appeared on tv shows
and
in the occasional movie with her very
first acting credit coming via a one-off
role on an episode of the tunnel arya's
next gig came a year later in 2014 when
she featured in the season 3 episode of
sherlock the sign of three
arya portrayed gail one of the women
sherlock holmes questioned during the
episode
as a contrast to the charmingly unhinged
lila gayle was arguably the most
straight-laced of the ladies and the
first one to log off when sherlock
started to imply that she might have
secrets
from 2016 to 2018 arya honed her genre
chops through her most visually
recognizable role
as flash on humans the british sci-fi
series that explored humanity's
difficult relationship with robotic
synths
arya's flash was a pink-haired nanny
synth who became sentient
a fellow synth called max soon rescues
flash and together they start building a
synth refuge on an abandoned lot
unfortunately flash died at the
beginning of the show's third season
when she ran into a group of humans
while running for supplies
after leaving the synth life behind in
2018 arya appeared on the itv medical
drama the good karma hospital
and the emilia clark starring romantic
comedy last christmas
and his becky on the psychological
workplace thriller miniseries sticks and
stones
however it wasn't until 2020 that things
got really exciting for arya
arya kicked the year off with a role on
the doctor who episode fugitive of
jedoon arya's character gatt was a
member of the doctor's species known as
timelords
gatt was chasing a previously unknown
version of the doctor played by joe
martin but ultimately died when she
fired a sabotaged weapon in a
confrontation with the two doctors
also in 2020 arya appeared on an episode
of the british netflix mystery thriller
the stranger
we also saw arya on the british comedy
drama series feel good where she played
lava the daughter of may's narcotics
anonymous sponsor maggie
with the umbrella academy season 2 the
talented arya has officially made the
jump stateside and judging by her role
as lyla it looks like she's out to make
a massive impact on the entertainment
industry
how high is her star set to rise well
before 2020 is over we'll also see arya
and the netflix heist movie red notice
in which she stars opposite dwayne
johnson ryan reynolds and gal gadot
with credits like that we have a feeling
that ritu arya has a pretty bright
future ahead
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one